[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur LCP nous
sommes ici en direct de l'Assemblée
nationale pour la 32e journée du Livre
politique qui va distinguer comme chaque
année des ouvrages qui ont séduit les
députés les journalistes et les
étudiants qui composent les différents
jurys alors vous allez assister à la
remise du prix des députés à la remise
du Prix du Livre politique et cet
après-midi à partir de 16h30 auront lieu
les remises des prix étudiants du Livre
politique LCP et du prix étudiant de la
BD politique LCP alors commençons par le
prix des députés laissez-moi d'abord
vous présenter les finalistes d'abord
Sylviane agazinski pour face à une
guerre sainte aux éditions Le Seuil
ensuite Sylvie caster pour 13 novembre
chronique d'un procès aux éditions les
échappées et puis le troisième finaliste
et Laurent Tello Voyage au bout de la
gauche
éditions Stock je vais maintenant
appeler à me rejoindre sur cette Mary
guevenou première question de
l'Assemblée nationale et membre du jury
des députés ainsi que Sylviane agazinski
finaliste du prix des députés pour son
ouvrage face à une guerre sainte
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
madame la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale Mesdames et Messieurs les
parlementaires messieurs les premiers
ministres madame et ministre chers amis
chers Sylvain magasin ski s'attaquer à
un sujet aussi baste aussi intrigant que
celui de la resurgence de la question
religieuse dans le monde
étudier les intersections complexes et
parfois confuse qui existe entre le fait
politique et le fait religieux
requiert une grande rigueur d'analyse
dans cet essai et l'exemple
face à une guerre sainte est un travail
aussi précis dans l'examen aussi vibrant
dans son message d'union nationale que
nécessaire au débat politique
aujourd'hui
nécessaire en effet parce que votre
livre chère Sylviane magasin ski à
l'heure des simplifications et des
confusions nous apportent des outils de
compréhension et de réflexion ciblées
pour mieux saisir dans toutes ces
dimensions la menace réelle aussi bien
physique qu'intelle que présente le
phénomène djihadiste
cette guerre sainte visant à mettre en
oeuvre un projet politique au religieux
et mener vous le rappelez à la fois
contre les fondements des démocraties
occidentales et contre les musulmans
eux-mêmes
avec votre ouvrage le lecteur prend
conscience de la double menace du
djihadisme celle d'un story un projet
extrémiste déterminé et de saper notre
modèle républicain
s'ensuit la mise en place par les
mouvements islamistes d'une croisade sur
plusieurs fronts contre les sociétés
occidentales et contre les musulmans
c'est dites-vous la pratique du
voilement des femmes qui a pour objet de
les contraindre et d'exposer leur
soumission ce sont les atteintes à nos
libertés à la liberté de la presse à la
liberté de caricature c'est la perverse
défense de la notion d'islamophobie
utilisée pour discréditer tout regard
critique sur les dérives islamistes
ce sont enfin tragiquement les atteintes
irréparables à la vie
et d'autre part l'autre arme de la
menace djihadiste corollaire de la
précédente touche la nation dans sa
dignité et son intégrité c'est la menace
interne de la perte du sens de la nation
la porte de votre réflexion lui aussi
est double on y trouve d'une part la
grande qualité objective du travail de
recherche la rigueur dans l'exposition
des thèses philosophiques et des
perspectives historiques exemple tirés
de l'histoire antique et de la théologie
anecdote empruntée à l'actualité donne à
votre ouvrage une indispensable
profondeur de champ
cet objectif cependant n'est pas aride
elle n'est pas détachée ou abstraite
bien au contraire car la voix qui la
porte la vôtre se fait entendre sans
toutefois couvrir l'objet de l'analyse
il y a donc en plus du constat une
lucidité subjective la marque d'une
personnalité celle d'une femme
philosophe ayant engagé un travail de
référence sur la politique des sexes
petite fille d'immigrés polonais
elle-même profondément attachée à la
France et à la langue
c'est aussi l'écho de cette voie si
singulière qui rend la lecture de ce
livre entraînante et utile votre
histoire particulière votre cheminement
intellectuel
transparaît à travers l'essai dans le
choix des exemples et des thématiques
abordées mais on les perçoit surtout
dans le dernier chapitre dans cet appel
à nous emparer collectivement de la
question qui sommes-nous
en faisant de cette question la
conclusion de votre livre vous nous
invitez à une salutaire prise de
conscience de la singularité de la
richesse de notre civilisation
européenne
plus encore vous nous exhortez à prendre
à bras le cœur cette question de la
nation en lui reconnaissant son histoire
son ancrage et ses valeurs universelles
non pas pour vivre dans le passé mais au
contraire pour lui donner un souffle
nouveau en la mettant en partage au
centre de nos vies de notre projet
commun et de notre avenir merci Madame
[Applaudissements]
merci Marie guesnou merci Sylviane
agazinski je vous invite à
rejoindre votre votre place
on va à présent vous présenter ce
deuxième finaliste il s'agit de Sylvie
caster 13 novembre chronique d'un procès
aux éditions Les échapper
et c'est Stéphane peu qui est qui est
député qui est membre du jury des
députés qui va nous rejoindre avec donc
Sylvie caster pour nous présenter cet
ouvrage
donc finaliste du prix des députés je
vous en prie
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente de l'Assemblée
messieurs les premiers ministres
mesdames et messieurs ont vos grades et
qualités qui sont nombreux ce matin
alors racontez ce procès hors norme
était une gageure et en même temps une
nécessité la mémoire a besoin de faire
elle a besoin de comprendre c'est de
tout cela qu'il fut question tout au
long de ce procès qui a duré près d'un
an
car avant d'être le temps de condamner
les coupables
ce fut d'abord le temps de déplier et de
mettre à plat cet écheveau terrible que
fut la nuit du 13 novembre et ce qui
conduisit
la vie presque de la vie presque
générale cette gageure fut tenue par le
procès elle est tout autant par ses
chroniques signées par Sylvie caster et
consignée dans ce livre 13 novembre
à commencer par la gageure de réussir à
dire l'abomination le livre réussit à le
faire en mettant ses pas dans les mots
des victimes des mots qui ne cherchent
jamais à soutirer une larme mais
simplement à donner à voix et ce faisant
nous entrons nous-même à tâtons dans le
Bataclan expérience qui ne peut laisser
indemne autre fait qui vous saute au
visage à la lecture de ces chroniques la
médiocrité des accusés en commençant le
livre on s'apprête à regarder le mal en
face le mal avec un grand M s'agissant
de daesh
mais loin de ce mal chimiquement pur on
découvre que cette violence la plus
extrême s'incarte dans des jeunes hommes
ordinaires on aperçoit jamais dans leur
déclaration la moindre construction
d'une théorie malade aucune cathédrale
diabolique mais un simple prêt à penser
une Vulgate famélique d'Islam
les accusés apparaissent dans leur
banalité et leur médiocrité c'est pour
soi c'est pourquoi alors que dans les
process en général vers les assassins
que l'attention se tourne avec une
certaine dose de fascination la lecture
de ces chroniques nous conduit au
contraire à nous tourner vers les
participes les victimes mais aussi les
policiers intervenus c'est probablement
ce qui va le plus retenir notre
attention tout au long du livre je pense
au commissaire de la BAC et assaisonne
dont le procès a permis d'établir enfin
au grand jour le rôle décisif qu'il
jouit au Bataclan et l'héroïsme dont il
fait preuve la grandeur est aussi du
côté des victimes je pense au jeune
homme qui a miraculeusement échappé du
Bataclan vient s'exprimer bien qu'il
vient exprimer sa détresse d'avoir
marché sur d'autres victimes pour
s'extraire de cet enfer je pense enfin à
Sonia cette jeune femme de ma ville
dionysienne qui permit de localiser de
neutraliser de terroristes se plaçant à
vie sous la menace de représailles au
procès l'assurera ce choix ne regrettant
pas le sacrifice d'une vie désormais
sous protection policière permanente
c'est bien la plus grande force de ce
livre et en réalité de ce procès pas
seulement de donner un visage et une
matière à la barbarie mais aussi de
mettre en lumière la dignité le courage
des victimes et au bout c'est aussi la
force de notre société de droit de notre
justice que le livre met en lumière face
à l'arbitraire de la violence terroriste
l'ouvrage montre merveilleusement
comment tout au long du procès notre
justice a su s'incarner dans le calme et
l'intelligence du président du tribunal
dans la volonté des parties civils
d'aller au bout de ce chemin de vérité
mais aussi dans le travail des avocats
se portant l'accusation comme ce portant
la défense merci Madame caster pour cet
ouvrage de tous les ouvrages que nous
avons pu lire sur le 13 novembre
c'est le plus complet c'est le plus
utile c'est celui qui se rendra le plus
grand service à la mémoire de cette
évoquement dans notre peuple je
conseille à tous moi qui suis dépité de
Saint-Denis qui était présent sur les
lieux jour des attentats au Stade de
France qui accompagne toujours
aujourd'hui des victimes de ces
attentats vous dire que ce livre il doit
être placé précieusement dans les
étagères de nos bibliothèques pour
transmettre aux générations futures ce
que fut cette tragique nuit du 13
novembre et du procès qui sont suivies
et qui rend hommage à notre pays et à
notre État de droit merci Madame
[Applaudissements]
et merci Stéphane peu pour ce bel éloge
du livre de Sylvie caster donc 13
novembre chronique d'un procès aux
éditions Les échapper et enfin pour le
dernier finaliste je vous propose de
d'accueillir donc Laurent Tello pour son
ouvrage au bout de la gauche chez Stock
et c'est Marie-Christine Daloz qui est
membre du jury et député du Jura qui va
vous le présenter
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs je vais par prendre le
protocole on va faire plus simple
avant de commencer je voudrais d'abord
dire un grand merci grand merci à
quelqu'un qui nous réunit dans le cadre
du Prix du Jury du livre des députés qui
a un esprit très vif qui a une vraie
curiosité et qui a réussi à transmettre
à l'ensemble des membres du jury sa
passion pour la lecture je parle bien
évidemment de l'espérance et je voudrais
vraiment qu'on l'applaudisse
nous pourrions discerter longtemps sur
les vertus sur les bienfaits de la
lecture mais ce n'est pas l'objectif de
notre journée car nous sommes ici toutes
et tous convaincus que la lecture c'est
une ouverture sur le monde
au détour des pages allez chercher
l'idée la conviction
l'explication ou simplement le voyage
c'est le sujet du livre que j'ai
particulièrement apprécié et je peux le
dire j'ai aimé cet ouvrage l'ouvrage de
laurentello ce livre nous Narc par le
menu une histoire contemporaine et
particulièrement d'actualité
député j'avais le sentiment d'avoir
suivi attentivement la campagne
présidentielle de 2022 mais je me suis
très vite rendu compte qu'il me manquait
quelques clés soit je n'avais pas porter
attention à un événement soit je n'avais
pas connaissance de cet événement et le
voyage de Laurent Tello a éclairé ou à
expliquer les échecs les réussites des
différentes composantes de la gauche
française il démontre les raisons des
décrochages mais aussi les espoirs les
illusions qui sont les moteurs d'une
campagne électorale
il aborde aussi et surtout la naissance
au travers d'une centaine de pages sans
trois précisément la naissance de la
nups cette association se regroupement
issus de la volonté initiale d'un
candidat de l'élection présidentielle
dans un accord quel qu'il soit et quel
qu'en soit le sujet l'objet qu'il soit
social c'est d'actualité qu'il soit
économique ou qu'il soit politique il y
a toujours
un gagnant imperdant on peut imaginer
qu'il y a deux gagnants mais le plus
souvent il y a toujours un gagnant
imperdant et voyages au bout de la
gauche racontent les tractations les
marchandages les pressions
éventuellement le chantage qui
a conclu à cet accord
merci Monsieur Tello de ces révélations
dans cet ouvrage bien sûr ce n'est pas
la nuit du 4 août on est d'accord
quel avenir pour la nups pourrait être
le sujet d'un prochain ouvrage monsieur
Tello je vous le suggère quel avenir
pour la nuit pêche car l'actualité nous
donne chaque jour l'occasion de nous
interroger sur cette thématique
je ne sais pas quelle relation vous avez
entretenu avec les ténors de la gauche
après la parution de votre ouvrage
mais je sais que pour faire
retenir votre ouvrage dans le jury
il a fallu être convaincante
car les élus de la nupestre n'étaient
pas franchement enthousiaste je le dis
poliment franchement enthousiaste
mais ça serait mieux connaître ma force
de conviction Voyage au bout de la
gauche on peut lui donner deux sens
Voyage au bout de la gauche c'est soit à
l'extrême à la fin enfin l'extrême de la
gauche soit au bout le bout du tunnel
vous savez bon vous avez rajouté un
petit une petite explication qui fait
que on n'est pas à la fin des choses
chacune chacun
analysera les différentes options que je
viens d'élaborer et j'espère que dans
les années futures dans les livres
d'histoire lorsqu'il sera question de
cette période et de la création de la
nups vous ferez référence dans les
éléments historiques de cette création
merci et mes sincères félicitations pour
cet ouvrage rafraîchissant facile à lire
tout public le meilleur exemple j'ai un
collègue qui dit régulièrement que quand
on lit un livre politique il faut avoir
envie de l'offrir à ses amis et bien
alors là je peux vous dire que non
seulement je l'ai offert je le prête
bien sûr aux personnes dont je suis sûr
et qui vont me le rendre mais c'est un
vrai bonheur merci
merci Marie-Christine Daloz alors le
suspense est donc à son comble vous
connaissez maintenant les trois
magnifiques ouvrages qui ont été
distinguées au terme de de délibération
difficile puisqu'on a eu trois trois
très beaux éloges qui va recevoir donc
le prix des députés pour remettre ce
prix je vous demande d'accueillir il y a
le Braun Pivet présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale
[Applaudissements]
veuillez m'excuser je prends le temps de
saluer des amis qui me sont chers
bonjour à tous je suis ravie d'être avec
vous aujourd'hui monsieur le Président
cher Louis Monsieur le Premier Ministre
cher Lionel Monsieur le Premier Ministre
cher manuel Monsieur et Madame et
messieurs les ministres madame la
première question chère Marie messieurs
et mesdames les députés mes chers
collègues madame la Présidente de lire
la politique chère Luz Perrault monsieur
le Président de lire la société cher
Cédric Landowski mesdames et messieurs
les membres du jury Mesdames et
Messieurs les auteurs mesdames et
messieurs
pêcheur Brigitte
la Journée du Livre politique dont c'est
la 32e édition fait quasiment partie de
l'institution parlementaire aujourd'hui
quant au prix des députés il s'agit d'un
processus délibératif très abouti
149-3 niveau de bloqué ce qui est rendu
possible par l'absence de toute
obstruction observons bien depuis
septembre en effet nos jurés se voient
intervalles réguliers il délibère dans
l'écoute et le respect mutuel en vue de
parvenir à un consensus et je crois que
c'est la meilleure manière de procéder
pour avancer le consensus en
l'occurrence c'est le choix de l'auteur
et du livre primé choix nécessairement
difficile
déchirant car les finalistes
mériteraient tous d'être lauréat ou
L'Oréal lauréate elle est députés qui
ont présenté chacun leur ouvrage
nous l'ont bien montré mais il faut
choisir c'est le lot de tous les
responsables politiques et cette année
le rose élu
et Madame Sylviane à kazinski pour face
à une guerre sainte aux éditions du
Seuil
bravo Madame
[Applaudissements]
chère Sylviane à gazinski vous
saisissant des relations entre le
politique et le religieux vous avez
abordé courageusement la grande question
du temps présent en faisant appel aux
ressources de la philosophie et de
l'histoire vous montrer comment la
France
dans le respect de la liberté de
conscience et fondée a refuser des
injonctions rétrogrades qui conduisent
au voilement des femmes et à
l'extinction de leur liberté ainsi
établissez-vous une distinction très
nette entre la simple observation d'une
foire religieuse et le projet politique
djihadiste qui nous faut combattre sans
complaisance
avec mes félicitations et au nom de
l'Assemblée nationale je suis heureuse
de vous donner la parole aujourd'hui
madame
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente je
suis un peu émue d'autant que j'ai pas
voulu préparer un texte écrit donc ce
que je vais faire surtout c'est exprimer
ma vie gratitude à l'égard de Luz Perrot
de l'Assemblée nationale et avant tout
bien sûr des membres de ce jury mesdames
et messieurs les députés
je vais vous faire un aveu très simple
c'est que lorsque j'ai appris que mon
livre était sélectionné pour ce prix et
bien j'ai eu très très envie de
l'obtenir c'est pas dans l'absolu si
vous voulez mais je pense que tout
auteur est très gratifié lorsqu'il
reçoit un prix littéraire mais recevoir
un prix littéraire
partir du choix des députés d'assemblée
nationale c'est-à-dire des représentants
de la nation c'était beaucoup pour moi
ça touchait disons ma fibre républicaine
disons le mot donc je suis très très
touchée d'avoir reçu ce prix et je vous
en remercie je préciserai que ce qui m'a
touché également c'est que des députés
tellement
travailler en tellement sur le présent
tellement sur l'actualité la plus
brûlante internationale nationale soit
intéressée par un livre qui a voulu lire
une actualité c'est vrai le jihad mais
pas seulement au fond le prosélytisme
islamisme en France mais bien au-delà de
la France et que c'est députés et pu
apprécier en tout cas distinguer
un regard qui a voulu puiser dans un
passé lointain et même très lointain
les sources n'ont pas les explications
exhaustives mais en tout cas les sources
d'une situation et donc le rapport très
très long très profond entre le
religieux et le politique entre les
trois grandes religieux et religions
ont-ils les croisades il y a un
historien inconnu qui a écrit un livre
qui s'appelle enfin bien connu
maintenant à cause de Pierre Nora mais
qui s'appelle le mythe croisade et en
fait quand on voit que nous occidentaux
européens nous sommes appelés les
croisés on voit qu'il y a quelque chose
de très très long
qui habite l'événement le plus actuel et
donc c'est cette perspective très longue
les passions qui l'anime comment les
comment il peut y avoir une survivance
et une résurgence de passion dont on
aurait pu penser que elles étaient
historiques elles étaient lointaines et
elles étaient dépassées et ce que je me
suis dit à ce moment-là c'est que notre
vision de l'histoire qui était celle
d'une histoire non seulement progressive
et progresse qui progressaient vers
quelque chose mais qui était tellement
animé par l'idée
d'un dépassement dialectique en tout cas
du fait qu'on ne revient pas en arrière
qu'on ne revienne pas en arrière alors
on ne revient pas en arrière certes mais
le passé n'est pas dépassé comme on
pourrait le penser il continue parfois
de vivre sous et forme cette nouvelle
mais enfin qui sont très révélatrices et
dont on comprend mieux le sens en
puisant dans l'histoire et puis la
deuxième chose vous l'avez dit madame la
Présidente c'était ma très grande
sensibilité à la question de l'égalité
des hommes et des femmes question
républicaines d'ailleurs également et
que bon il y a eu une impulsion aussi
chez moi ce que j'appelle une une
émotion motrice enfin sentiment moteur
qui était que il n'est pas possible
contiennent dans notre pays un discours
pour lequel les femmes doivent être
mises sous une tutelle et le voile n'est
rien d'autre que le symbole de cette
tutelle et donc je suis remonté là aussi
très loin dans l'histoire pour montrer
que déjà avant l'Islam avant l'islamisme
bien sûr ça a toujours le voile a
toujours été ce symbole de la miss sous
tutelle des femmes et de leurs droits
inégaux par rapport notamment dans la
vie familiale je veux pas être trop
longue donc j'ai voulu aussi être le
plus nuancé possible
parce que je ne voulais absolument pas
confondre les excès du prosélytisme
islamisme ou du djihad bien entendu je
ne voulais certainement pas le confondre
avec la vie des musulmans avec la
pratique que j'appellerais
traditionnelle de cette religion et
qu'il faut rester très vigilant sur le
fait de ne pas de ne pas mélanger ces
deux ces deux aspects
au fond de la religion aujourd'hui et de
la religion musulmane donc merci à
nouveau bon j'étais trop longue merci à
tous
[Applaudissements]
félicitations donc Sylviane à magasin ce
qui vous remportez ce Prix du Livre des
députés face à une guerre sainte aux
éditions Le Seuil et félicitations
également à Sylvie caster et laurentello
finaliste de ce prix des députés il y a
une bonne pivée vous restez avec moi car
le jury a décidé de remettre un prix
spécial pour seul l'espoir apaise la
douleur aux éditions Flammarion c'est un
livre de Simone Veil et je vais inviter
Pierre-François Weil à nous rejoindre
sur scène pour recevoir ce prix il y a
le brune Pivet vous allez nous expliquer
la décision du jury
[Applaudissements]
il faut toujours
innover et c'est ce que j'essaye de
faire depuis le début de ma présidence
en donnant carte blanche à des artistes
au Palais Bourbon ou en organisant ici
dans cette même galerie des fêtes des
débats citoyens ouverts à tous intitulé
l'assemblée des idées il faut aussi
avoir de la mémoire
en honorant les grandes voies de notre
histoire politique et parlementaire
cette année nous innovons en créant un
prix spécial tout en célébrant une
grande dame à qui notre pays doit
beaucoup
Simone Veil
dans les éditions Flammarion et Lina
publie le bouleversant témoignage seul
l'espoir apaise la douleur
une lecture indispensable
pour comprendre tout à la fois l'horreur
concentrationnaire
et la vitalité avec laquelle dans
l'après-guerre les rescapés de la Shoah
se sont investis dans la reconstruction
et la modernisation d'une Europe
dévastée
dès le mois de novembre 2022 tout près
d'ici dans le jardin des quatre colonnes
j'ai inauguré un buste de Simone Veil
dans l'enceinte du Palais Bourbon
au pied de ce buste j'ai fait planter
des rosiers Marie Curie sa variété
préférée en novembre ce n'était que de
frêles plan rabougri à la merci du froid
mais on se débute printemps ils ont
commencé à pousser ne tarderont pas à
fleurir
vivant symbole de cet espoir qui a
toujours animé Simone Veil d'une
extraordinaire énergie
en déportation est plus tard en butte
aux attaques les plus basses jamais elle
ne s'est découragée toujours elle s'est
battue pour sa survie pour ses idées
pour les droits de toutes les femmes
pour l'Europe et pour la réconciliation
franco-allemande
ce prix spécial au fond reste un bien
modeste hommage à celle à qui nous
devons tant mais il a tout son sens dans
le contexte que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui
car les droits des femmes sont
en danger en Afghanistan en Iran bien
sûr mais aussi dans de grandes
démocraties où le droit à l'avortement
est de plus en plus remis en question
saluer la mémoire de Simone Veil dans
cette maison qui vient de voter à
l'unanimité la constitutionnalisation de
l'IVG ces témoigner que notre République
tient à la grande loi de 1975 qu'il
égalisa enfin l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse en France
et pour nous parler
peut-être plus intimement de Simone Veil
de sa vie de son message nous avons la
chance d'accueillir ici son fils
Pierre-François veille à qui je suis
toujours très heureuse de céder la
parole monsieur
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente
monsieur le président
monsieur les premiers ministres
madame le ministre monsieur le ministre
mesdames et messieurs
maman
aimait infiniment lire
et énormément la politique
et comme elle avait beaucoup d'affection
pour lui sperro elle ne ratait jamais
une Journée du Livre politique
elle était là toujours accompagnée de
son mari mon père
et donc
au moins un samedi par an
elle s'échappait de sa famille elle nous
manquait pour être présente ici
à cette journée alors
pour moi madame le Président c'est une
très grande émotion aujourd'hui d'être
là
non pas pour parler à sa place bien sûr
mais pour ce prix spécial que que les
députés que vaut députés madame
présidente ont choisi de lui remettre
pour l'honorer
tout de suite je voudrais dire et vous
me pardonnerez cette observation
peut-être
un peu jeanrée autrefois on aurait dit
sexiste madame le Président mais je
pense qu'elle serait particulièrement
heureuse
que que que ce prix spécial arrive
aujourd'hui ou l'Assemblée nationale et
pour la première fois je crois en France
dans notre pays
présidé par une femme
d'être la présidente du Parlement
européen la première femme
présidente mais la première président
élu au suffrage univers du Parlement
européen élu suffrage universel avait
été pour elle une consécration tout à
fait importante et une partie de sa vie
politique tout à fait considérable et je
sais qu'aujourd'hui elle serait
elle serait particulièrement
particulièrement ému et honoré de ce
choix alors
je voudrais dire que
je viens de découvrir comme vous madame
la Présidente le
lauréat ou la lauréate de de du prix des
députés et il me semble que
peut-être cela sonne en résonance
de de votre livre madame magasin qui que
j'ai lu et que j'ai beaucoup aimé qui
est bien qui qui tente de de tirer le
voile
que c'est société
qui oppriment que ces sociétés qui elle
a démocratie essaye d'imposer
sur sur les femmes et donc sur notre sur
notre vie à tous
un mot si vous me permettez du du livre
qui a été
choisi de enfin du livre de maman seul
l'espoir
apaise la souffrance un mot pour pour
remercier
l'Institut national de l'audiovisuel
Lina cette formidable ce formidable
service public
qui avait
à la demande de la fondation de la
mémoire de la Shoah
qui vous doit beaucoup Monsieur le
Premier Ministre à vous et au président
Chirac puisque cette en 1997 ou 98 que
je crois vous avez tous les deux décidés
de la constitution de cette de cette
institution dont la présidence a été
confiée à maman en je vous en remercie
monsieur le Président je vous en
remercie parce que cette
fondation tous les jours
contribue à ce que vous évoquiez à la
mémoire et à ce
travail tout à fait considérable qui
permet à aux historiens de de travailler
de trouver les éléments de réponse aux
négationnistes de tout poil qui est
encore aujourd'hui malheureusement
résonne notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux l'objet de votre coloc
d'aujourd'hui
Lina donc à la demande de de la
fondation à la demande précisément de
maman avait dans les années 2004
2005-2006
enregistrée un très grand nombre de
témoignages d'anciens déportés et il se
trouve évidemment le premier de ces
témoignages et c'est celui de la
présidente de la Fondation pour la
mémoire de la Shoah de l'époque de maman
mais il se trouve que
pour une raison qui reste inconnue les
droits n'avaient jamais été cédés de
telle sorte que c'est ce témoignage ne
pouvait pas être exploité en 2017 en
2018 ou en 2019 Linas en était mue et a
voulu mettre ce témoignage en ligne et
par conséquent nous a demandé à mon
frère et moi
de donner les droits bien évidemment
nous l'avons fait le témoignage a été a
été mis en ligne je sais qu'il a été
énormément regardé mais je veux aussi te
remercier non seulement Lina mais mes
Flammarion
car sans cet éditeur qui en co-partage
avec Lina a repris ce texte et repris ce
témoignage et bien ce livre n'existerait
pas et il n'aurait pas pu aujourd'hui
recevoir ce prix spécial alors
à l'issue de mon propos je voudrais dire
à nouveau tous mes remerciements au prix
du Livre politique à
l'espéro au député et à vous madame le
Président et et inciter nous inciter
tous à lire nous ne lisons jamais assez
il faut lire et c'est par le c'est par
le livre que que nous pouvons porter nos
nos convictions au monde je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
alors Pierre-François avec vous avez
esquissé le combat de votre maman pour
donner aux femmes la place qu'elle
mérite dans la société vous souhaitiez
aussi pour suivre ce combat aujourd'hui
en disant un mot pour les femmes
iraniennes
je
l'ai dit un bouchez le président
le jury des livres des livres le
juridique à Honoré madame agadezki mais
je crois que
et je suis frappé de ce que
nous évoquons aujourd'hui à votre coloc
le
les réseaux sociaux
plusieurs des intervenants on dit
concernant les réseaux sociaux qu'après
tout c'est un outil et que comme tous
les outils on peut en attendre le
meilleur mais il faut toujours en
craindre le pire
le pire nous le connaissons nous le
vivons nous combattants et
qui mieux que
Richard Malka par exemple tout à l'heure
dans son intervention peut exprimer ce
qu'il faut ce qu'il faut faire pour
faire en sorte que dans nos démocraties
les réseaux sociaux les réseaux sociaux
ne
diffuse pas les haines qu'il diffuse
mais les réseaux sociaux c'est aussi la
possibilité dans
les dictatures pour un certain nombre de
gens de s'exprimer de porter leur voix
je suis frappé de ce que les femmes
iraniennes le combat des femmes
iraniennes et portés par ces réseaux
sociaux
et alors que ce combat est porté par ses
réseaux sociaux que ces réseaux sociaux
sont un outil pour elle pour s'exprimer
pour
faire connaître leur combat pour faire
connaître cette révolution contre cette
dictature et bien je suis frappé que à
l'inverse de ces réseaux sociaux dans
les pays démocratiques nous ne faisons
pas suffisamment pour relayer ses voies
pour relayer ses discours pour relayer
ses paroles qui ont tellement de mal à
sortir de cette dictatures et qu'au fond
et bien
je ne sais pas si par facilité il faut
dire que nous nous jetons un voile
dessus non je n'irai pas jusque là mais
en tout cas nous ne combattons pas
suffisamment alors
je crois que
il faut il faut relayer ce combat je
pense je pense que maman il
le ferait si elle était là aujourd'hui
je pense qu'elle relèverait ce combat
des femmes iraniennes qui est un qui est
une leçon de courage une leçon de une
leçon de combat et en définitive une
leçon de vie je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci à tous les deux merci également au
finaliste du prix des députés
nous allons à présent poursuivre cet
hommage pour les femmes iraniennes en
accueillant une voix tout à fait
singulière qui va leur rendre hommage
pour ces femmes qui se battent pour leur
liberté et pour vivre libre avec un
combat très courageux depuis la mort de
Macha et Minnie contre la police des
morts contre le régime démolages vous
demande d'accueillir Marjane Satrapi
réalisatrice actrice et scénariste
iranienne
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
j'ai eu la chance en fait de connaître
votre maman de l'avoir rencontré au
salon de l'histoire de Blois donc je
suis ravie et très émue d'être présenté
par vous
je suis également très ému d'être là
dans cet Assemblée nationale que
j'espère en avoir un jour la même dans
mon pays dans mon autre patrie parce que
j'en ai deux la France et l'Iran
le combat des femmes iraniennes n'a pas
commencé en fait hier d'ailleurs tout le
combat des Iraniens pour la démocratie
c'est pas un combat qui ont commencé le
16 septembre
si on regarde juste en histoire récente
vous ne trouverez aucun pays au monde
qui a fait autant de révolution pour
acquérir la démocratie je pars de la
Révolution constitue
1905 les révoltes de 1919
1953 avec le coup d'État contre mossader
le Mouvement Vert et
à chaque fois notre peuple a donné des
morts et c'est pas comme si les femmes
iraniennes et se sont réveillés soudain
l'année dernière nous avons commencé à
avoir qui a commencé là et chaque année
on l'a fait reculer d'un peu millimètre
par millimètre et c'était pas un effet
de mode c'était pas une coquetterie
on parlait de notre droit de vivre avec
notre corps avec nos cheveux que si le
bon Dieu ne voulait pas que les hommes
le voient
et nous aurait peut-être fait chauve
mais il nous l'a donné donc autant le
montrer pour arriver à un petit
petit foulard et
en fait il y a eu une autre révolution
féministe en Iran en 1979 exactement
mars 1979 quelques semaines après
ce qu'on appelle la réussite de la
Révolution islamique
dans lequel beaucoup de femmes des
milliers de femmes dont ma mère a
participé j'avais 9 ans j'ai participé
aussi mais nous n'avions que très peu
d'hommes mon père en faisait partie
peut-être une centaine pas plus et même
à l'époque la gauche révolutionnaire de
l'opposition
ne nous a pas soutenu en disant que ceci
était un combat de classes sociales et
qui n'était que ce n'était pas le
problème d'actualité en oubliant au
passage que les droits de la femme sont
les droits de la société
et bien nous avons dû nous battre tant
bien que mal et cette fois je suis sûre
après tous ces révolutions dont je vous
et je vous ai parlé depuis le début du
20e siècle pourquoi je pense que nous
allons réussir parce que
la raison est simple parce que la
démocratie c'est une culture
ce n'est pas quelque chose qu'on offre à
une société comme les américains ont
voulu faire en allant les bombarder et
en mettant deux machines de Coca-Cola ça
ne marche pas comme ça
c'est une acquis culturelle c'est une
acquis voilà
en fait il va avoir la culture
démocratique cette partie là
extraordinairement ça s'est passé très
très vite en Iran c'est-à-dire en espace
de 40 ans
à cause de cette propagande islamique
islamiste et très très fort des mots là
moi je suis allée dans les écoles en
fait j'ai grandi dans les écoles
des mots là dans notre pays qui étaient
supposés de faire de nous des musulmans
bien fanatiques et ben ça crée l'effet
complètement inverse parce que dès lors
où vous savez les réécrire et ben vous
ne lisez pas que ce qu'on vous donne des
réécrire vous lisez tout et donc en 79
nous avions 60%
d'illettrés en Iran aujourd'hui on en a
plus que 18%. et il y a quelque chose
d'extraordinaire qui s'est passé c'est
que avec ce questionnement de la
religion de façon fanatique cette fois
nos hommes sont derrière nous donc ce
qu'on appelle le combat des familles
indiennes
fait que nous avons en face de nous une
première révolution féministe qui est
soutenue par les hommes nous avons des
milliers d'hommes qui sont aujourd'hui
en prison politique qui de même que les
femmes sont torturées violées oui violet
tué et ne les oublions pas parce que
c'est le combat de ces hommes l'histoire
iranienne en réalité c'est une c'est du
pays quand même
l'histoire en continu la plus longue de
nos civilisations mais c'est une espèce
de continuité dans la rupture et après
toutes les invasions arabes Mongols tout
ça on s'est relevé comme le phénix et
donc cette république islamique en
réalité c'est une anomalie pour notre
peuple
et pourquoi elle ne peut pas
survivre nous seulement parce que nous
avons acquis la culture démocratique ce
qui est 90% du travail et de 10% ça va
être en fait la partie politique de la
faire qui va prendre du temps j'espère
le plus court possible mais la raison
pour laquelle nous allons
réussir c'est parce que vous avez en
Iran une population très moderne surtout
les jupes chez les jeunes avec lesquels
je suis en contact de façon de tous les
jours
et qui aspire à la démocratie qui se
voit égaux avec leur sœur leurs
camarades
leurs cousines leurs filles
nous sommes dans un pays où 60% de nos
étudiants sont des femmes que 70% de nos
ingénieurs sont des femmes des femmes
qui travaillent et évidemment la liberté
des femmes d'abord commencent par
avoir une indépendance économique
mais nous allons réussir parce que vous
ne pouvez pas avoir un peuple si moderne
si
tourner vers la démocratie occidentale
juste pour rappel le peuple iranien je
vous parle de peuples iraniens et très
amoureux de la démocratie très tournée
vers l'Occident ça a toujours été le cas
dans toute la région c'est la population
le plus pro-occidentale qui existe
et ce peuple ne peut pas être dirigé par
un régime obscurantiste qui a des outils
modernes dans les mains des gens qui
viennent de Moyen-âge et ce qui nous
ramène à ce qu'on disait en fait au
début avec Maître Richard Michael qui
par passage et aussi mon avocat
bonjour Richard
ces choses là n'est pas possible c'est
c'est nous allons réussir et j'espère
que cette fois l'Occident parce que
malheureusement au cours de cette
histoire l'Occident a toujours été du
mauvais côté de l'histoire concernant la
question iranienne toujours
donc j'espère que l'Occident pour une
fois il va être du bon côté que vous
allez porter notre parole nous en avons
besoin nous nous demandons pas à
l'Europe en fait ni d'intervention
militaire ni rien de tout ça mais
l'Europe est aujourd'hui le garant de la
démocratie dans le monde l'Amérique est
à la dérive parce que même si Trump il
n'est plus le Président il a contaminé
la société américaine où tout est permis
maintenant on s'est permis d'être
raciste et d'homophobes tout est permis
ces gens-là ils contaminent nos sociétés
comment français des émours et de peine
même s'il ne gagne pas il contamine
notre
c'était également
la Chine la Russie tout ça on oublie
donc le seul garant de la démocratie
dans le monde et l'Europe et en Europe
le pays le plus puissant pour les
questions démocratiques et la France
parce que c'est ici même que les droits
de l'homme ont été écrits et parce que
le peuple iranien donjon fait partie
nous nous méfions énormément des
Américains et des Anglais qui ont
toujours voulu nous coloniser nous
piquer notre pétrole
par contre on a eu toujours des rapports
très cordiaux et très civilisés avec la
France donc merci de m'avoir donné la
parole et merci de m'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]
merci Marjane satrapie pour pour ce bel
hommage et ce combat que vous menez au
nom de toutes les femmes iraniennes qui
se battent pour leur liberté le courage
merci aussi pour ce courage d'avoir
parlé devant l'Assemblée nationale le
courage il en faut aussi en politique ce
n'est pas Manuel Valls qui va me
contredire lui qui vient de sortir ce
livre le courage guider leur pas aux
éditions tallendier François-Xavier
Lefranc est membre du jury du Prix du
Livre politique va nous rejoindre
justement pour pour nous parler du
courage en politique en ces temps
difficiles
il fallait bien un livre pour le
rappeler il faut du courage pour faire
de la politique
c'est le courage cette vertu très
mystérieuse écrivez vous Monsieur le
Premier Ministre Manuel Valls c'est le
courage qui s'exprime dans les moments
vertigineux de bascule quand le monde
vacille quand il semble se perdre
il faut du courage pour être un acteur
décisif de l'histoire comme Clémenceau
en 1918 comme Churchill et de Gaulle en
40 comme Willy brand s'agenouillant
devant le monument aux héros de Varsovie
le 7 décembre 1970
des hommes des femmes comme Louise
Michel l'héroïne de la bataille du fort
d'ici comme nadalida et aussi Mandelstam
résistant à l'oppression stalinienne
comme Simone Veil à Auschwitz ou
affrontant la haine quand elle défendait
la loi sur l'intervention volontaire de
grossesse sur en 1975
le courage guidait le repas 12 destins
célèbres face à l'Histoire le livre de
Manuel Valls à toute sa place en cette
Journée du Livre politique
en cette heure où l'action politique est
tellement décrié
l'ouvrage passionnant
utile nous raconte des actes exemplaires
et s'il lui manque beaucoup de noms
c'est qu'une bibliothèque ne suffirait
pas à raconter les courageuses et les
courageux de tous les temps
les célèbres les anonymes les héros de
la chose publique celles et ceux d'hier
celles et ceux d'aujourd'hui
le livre de Manuel Valls nous rappelle
des parcours exceptionnels des moments
d'histoire où le courage a été la
solution
ce livre d'histoire est finalement un
livre pour aujourd'hui parce que
qu'est-ce que le courage en politique
aujourd'hui est-ce que ce n'est pas
aussi le courage de la nuance titre on
s'en souvient du bel ouvrage de Jean
behrenbaum vous l’évoquez dans votre
livre le courage de la nuance
qu'amulent l'appelait quand il
condamnait l'outrance quand il affirmait
la démesure est un confort toujours elle
est une carrière parfois
le courage en politique
n'est-ce pas aussi celui des citoyennes
et des citoyens qui s'expriment quoi
qu'il en coûte
n'est-ce pas aussi celui de Yannick
Morez maire de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins
devant sa maison et sa voiture en feu
menacé de mort comme tant d'autres élus
sur d'être plateformes numériques que
nos sociétés n'ont pas eu le courage de
réguler
quand elle porte atteinte aux droits
fondamentaux des personnes c'est à dire
tous les jours
qu'est-ce que le courage en politique il
y a dans votre livre énormément de une
belle matière à réflexion pour répondre
à cette question merci
[Applaudissements]
François-Xavier lefran vous avez évoqué
le courage de Simone Veil frère François
Weil vous avez également lu le livre de
Manuel Valls et vous vouliez nous dire
un petit mot
oui
Monsieur le Premier Ministre cher manuel
la dictature de la dictature des
comme on dirais-je des agendas font que
le jury du Livre politique n'a pas pu
n'a pas pu
mettre votre votre ouvrage dans les
différents ouvrages que nous avons
réalisé
duquel nous avons voté et et choisis un
lauréat qui sera annoncé tout à l'heure
mais nous tenions et ça a été fait déjà
par Monsieur lefran mais nous tenions à
vous dire combien cette éloge du courage
est essentielle aujourd'hui alors
rappelons tout d'abord que six temps
Winston Churchill vous nous rappeler que
le courage est la première des qualités
parce qu'elle est celle qui rend les
autres possibles
et puis
si tant les exemples de courage
de ces 12 de ces 12 parcours qui vont
bien sûr du verbe et vous consacrer un
chapitre de votre ouvrage à
vous consacrer un chapitre de votre
ouvrage au discours croisé
du général de Gaulle et de et de et de
southston l'un
en mai 40 et l'autre en bien sûr son
discours du 18 juin 1940 et puis
et puis du geste du simple geste du
geste encore appelé tout à l'heure par
Monsieur Lefranc du geste de de Willy
Brandt
résistant résistant allemand de la
première heure maire de Berlin puis puis
chancelier de l'Allemagne fédérale qui
luttant pour le rapprochement de
la et la réunification de son pays quand
il est à quand il est au monument du
ghetto de Varsovie en novembre ou en
décembre 1970 ne parle pas
mettons à genoux et
témoigne par ce par ce geste de la de la
de
ce qu'il
exprime comme sens de la de la
responsabilité non pas de la culpabilité
vous tenez à le rappeler elle souligner
et Willy insistait là-dessus non pas de
la culpabilité mais de la de la
responsabilité du peuple allemand qu'il
porte parce qu'il est parce qu'il est
son chancelier alors que lui-même était
depuis 1933 avait toujours résisté et
vient de la responsabilité qu'il porte
vous vous exprimez ce courage
ce courage monsieur le Premier ministre
que vous avez eu à
porter pour pour nous tous lors des
épouvantables attentats que nous avons
subi en 2015 et en 2016 et votre votre
livre s'ouvre sur le rappel de à la
mémoire de Charb ce magnifique
dessinateur ce directeur de Charlie
Hebdo qui a mis sa vie en péril et à
payer par à payer de sa vie le courage
de tous les jours de notre liberté de
notre conception
essentielle au monde de ce qu'est la
liberté de la presse le droit de
critiquer jusqu'à la caricature jusqu'à
la caricature même lorsqu'elle déplaît
même lorsqu'elle énerve même lorsqu'elle
agace mais ce droit fondamental qui fait
que la France a cette place tellement
particulière dans dans le monde alors
pour ce pour ce livre donc
bien qu'il le remporte pas le prix
puisqu'il n'est pas une concourt pas qui
qui doit figurer dans nos bibliothèques
quelqu'un disait tout à l'heure que les
livres qui restent sont les livres qu'on
conserve sa bibliothèque et bien ce
livre là moi je le conserverai dans ma
bibliothèque je vous incite à lui lire
je vous je vous pousse à lui lire je
vous remercie je vous remercie surtout
d'applaudir Emmanuel Valls
[Applaudissements]
merci Pierre-François Weil je vais
inviter les finalistes et lauréate de ce
prix des députés à rejoindre leur place
merci merci à vous parce que nous allons
à présent procéder à la remise du Prix
du Livre politique le jury est présidé
par l'ancienne ministre de la Culture
Roselyne Bachelot qui remettra dans
quelques instants ce prix alors
laissez-moi d'abord vous présenter les
trois finalistes d'abord Franz Olivier
Giesbert pour histoire intime de la
Cinquième République c'est le tome 2 aux
éditions Gallimard
[Applaudissements]
le second ouvrage celui de Chloé Morin
on aura tout essayé aux éditions Fayard
[Applaudissements]
et puis Laurent Tello à nouveau
finaliste pour voyager au bout de la
gauche aux éditions Stock
[Applaudissements]
alors pour vous présenter les trois
ouvrages retenus je vais d'abord
demander à Anna Cabana de venir nous
rejoindre membre du jury pour présenter
le livre de Franz Olivier Giesberg
distinguer pour cet ouvrage donc
histoire intime de la 5ème république
chez Gallimard c'est le tome 2 il me
semble que vous étiez déjà l'année
dernière pour le tome 1 alors pourquoi
bonjour à tous
cher France c'est à toi que je vais
m'adresser je suis prête à parier qu'un
écolier du 23ème siècle verra les règnes
de De Gaulle Pompidou Giscard et des
suivants à travers ton œil à travers
votre œil vous vous oblige comme nous
voyons le règne de Saint-Louis de Louis
XIV de Charles X à travers le regard de
Joinville de Saint-Simon et de
Chateaubriand vaut mettre
cet écolier déjà électrisé par le
sursaut le premier tome de votre
histoire intime de la Cinquième
République se penchera sur le deuxième
la belle époque et il aura sous les yeux
une histoire complètement subjective et
or idéologie un bonheur en ces temps
idéologiquement moralisateur donc une
histoire qui raconte l'éducation
politique comme on dit l'éducation
sentimentale d'un franco-américain vous
qui devient un amoureux fou de la France
et qui se demande pourquoi et comment ce
pays qui a été si grand et devenu si
petit sirabougri vous avez 37 arts
d'entremêler le récit politique et les
souvenirs personnels qui fait de vous et
vous le savez le fils improbable que
Saint-Simon a eu avec Norman maylor
alors notre écolier de lent 200200 et
ben il bénéficiera de clés
d'interprétation unique et jubilatoire
comme par exemple Ninove que c'est Nino
Ferrer qui a prophétisé l'écologie avec
la maison près de la fontaine je suis
sûr que tous vos lecteurs comme moi sont
allés voir les paroles et alors moi je
me suis pas dit ça crée Nino je me suis
dit ça crée France capable d'aller
dénicher la pépite dans tout terrain
capable de nous faire une histoire de la
vie quotidienne et de la culture en même
temps qu'une histoire politique alors
vous allez peut-être me trouver
grandiloquentes vous vous direz c'est
normal il a été son chef son maître elle
a vu le grand fente de près et elle en
reste ébloui à jamais et ben vous aurez
raison mais quand même France il faut
dire ici qu'avec c'est de se diptyque
bientôt triptyque et bien tu es entré
dans fin dans la trempe de 20 juin vide
d'un Saint-Simon d'un château brillant
oui je le dis impertinent lucide revenu
tout et dupe de rien comme toi ces
écrivains historiens conteurs
mémorialiste qui cherchait le mystère de
ce pays unique si on chanteur est
souvent si inquiétant
et donc avec un cortège de visiustre
croquée par tes soins provocateurs et
mystique car tu es assurément le plus
bouddhiste de nos journalistes mais mais
un bouddhiste qui est fasciné parce
qu'il fascine le moins les vrais
bouddhistes le pouvoir pour mieux sans
moquer encore et encore l'ironie est à
musique une musique nostalgique et
pessimiste bien sûr mais mais ce livre
est une chronique de la décadence
française on le sait mais il laisse
aussi ça et là sachant ça l'espoir à la
Renaissance et même à la résurrection
avec toi on ne perd jamais de vue la
possibilité loin très très loin d'une
toute petite lumière au bout du tunnel
fog quel nom quand même quand on y pense
des initiales qui sonnent comme un
programme comme un brouillard aussi un
brouillard répandu dès ton Aurore face à
tous ceux qui prétendent et vouloir te
réduire t'interpréter avec simplisme
parce que tu es
surprenant multiple et il fallait bien
que tu avances dans la vie avec ces
initiales quand je réfléchis aux autres
initiales anglaises qui auraient pu être
à la hauteur je pense à ink ink l'encre
celle que jette le poulpe l'animal au 9
cerveau paraît-il pour se défendre ou
pour avancer masquer l'encre pour écrire
aussi et on y trempant évidemment cette
plume éblouissante cette encre vital
dont on existence et de l'encre tu en as
utilisé j'ai déménagé récemment et alors
j'ai rangé ma bibliothèque il y avait du
front de ce partout plus d'une étagère
il y a plusieurs fronts dans chacun des
livres de France au moins 3 il y a le
premier c'est le jeune homme ambitieux
le Bel Ami qui est de la fort pardon
avait distingué en faisant le
compte-rendu de son premier roman
monsieur Adrien le deuxième on le
connaît bien surtout les journalistes
c'est le balsacien spectateur du monde
de la comédie humaine et politique
le troisième c'est le romancier
spinosiste et au fond avec cette belle
époque c'est comme si les trois frontz
convergent des ruisseaux au fond vers un
fleuve évident et je suis sûr que tu es
bon maître peuvent se réjouir François
Furet Jean-Daniel Julien Green du haut
de la pyramide de papier que tu es en
train de bâtir et bien je vais les
imagine je les imagine te regarder et je
les vois sourire presque autant que nous
parce que quel plaisir tu nous donnes
ceux et au fond il y a véritablement un
plaisir d'autant plus grand qu'on sait
qu'il a une suite à un moment de la
Belle Époque tu cites Mitterrand
qui te dit il faut savoir profiter de la
France et bien moi j'ai envie de dire
ici devant vous tous et au nom de vous
tous il faut savoir profiter de France
[Applaudissements]
merci Anna Gabana pour ce très bel
hommage à prendre s’olivier Gilbert
histoire intime de la Cinquième
République et c'est le tome 2 après le
sursaut nous allons maintenant vous
présenter le deuxième finaliste et c'est
Bertrand delay qui est membre du jury
qui va nous parler de cet ouvrage on
aura tout essayé de Chloé Morin venez
vers train si vous voulez bien nous
rejoindre pour nous présenter donc cet
ouvrage
madame la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale
monsieur des premiers ministres madame
la ministre chers Roselyne mesdames et
messieurs les députés mesdames messieurs
alors lorsqu'on voit le titre de
l'ouvrage de Chloé Morin on aura tout
essayé on est d'abord saisi d'un vertige
parce que c'est effectivement la phrase
qu'on entend peut au prou dans la bouche
des électeurs de Marine Le Pen non qu'il
faille ignorer cette réalité mais on se
dit que vient donc faire Chloé Morin de
la Fondation Jean Jaurès autour de cette
affirmation aux accents populistes et
bien Chloé Morin a fait une enquête un
travail intelligent sensible pour tenter
de mettre des mots m ots
sur nos mots maux
et de ce point de vue on peut être
rassuré son ouvrage fourmille de propos
d'analyses pertinente salutaire parfois
même salvatrice Chloé Morin met ainsi en
lumière sur ce qui dysfonctionne dans la
France d'aujourd'hui et cela sans table
son ouvrage et tout à la fois rassurant
et dérangeant
rassurant car en réalité on perçoit
beaucoup de sagesse de pertinence à la
lecture de certaines des analyses à
travers les paroles des acteurs qu'elle
a recueilli et contrairement à des lieux
communs souvent répétés elles nous
montrent qu'il y a peu d'impensés parmi
les acteurs de la société civile
d'aujourd'hui les acteurs de la société
politique mais ce livre est aussi
dérangeant
car il met en lumière ou en évidence
j'allais dire nos impuissons collectives
ces constats sont là mais ils
apparaissent comme désolant au regard de
nos incapacités à morcer un quelconque
mouvement
parce qu'il met des mots sur nos mots
donc ce livre est un préalable
indispensable pour qui veut comprendre
la réalité du moment
[Applaudissements]
on va à présent accueillir Bruno jeudi
qui va nous présenter donc le troisième
finaliste de ce Prix du Livre politique
c'est donc le prix finaliste Laurent
hello pour voyager au bout de la gauche
madame la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale Monsieur le Premier Ministre
madame la Présidente cher Roselyne cher
Laurent Tello alors ceci n'est pas un
récit de campagne ceci est un voyage au
bout de la gauche c'est marqué dessus et
je dois dire que le titre est bien
trouvé la flèche est toujours à gauche
on descend donc le toboggan de cette
année 2022
pendant 277 pages c'est vertigineux
c'est cruel c'est sanglant parfois très
drôle oui oui on a beaucoup ri et Rosine
Bachelot a beaucoup ri je peux vous le
dire laurentello son auteur
plume du monde à voyager pendant une
année au milieu de ce paysage dévasté du
PS au PCF des écolos insoumis on
accompagne donc notre confrère dans une
déambulation
qui fut
parmi les plus grands partis politiques
français et c'est pour ça que c'est
vertigineux je dois dire que Laurent
hello a le chic pour pimenter
d'anecdotes son voyage au bout de la
gauche exemple on se marre franchement
quand il raconte cette soirée du 10
avril le pire premier tour du PS lors
d'une élection présidentielle j'ose le
rappeler un 75% des voies recueillies
par an Hidalgo
une soirée cauchemar au point que
Olivier Faure et ses deux compars ne
trouveront pas ou éprouveront 1000
peines pour rallier le nouveau siège du
Parti socialiste c'est à Ivry-sur-Seine
c'est beau mais c'est loin visiblement
comme disait Chirac il y a le récit de
campagne il y a aussi l'avenir de la
gauche qui rime avec nupes affreux
acronymes à la sonorité protéiforme mais
finalement rentrée dans leur langage
courant on a tous adopté pour le
meilleur et pour le pire la nupes finit
la nuque la nups c'était l'horreur pour
les commentateurs à la télé des premiers
jours petit rappel la nupes nouvelle
union populaire écologique et sociale un
mariage de raison ou de des raisons qui
tient toujours
Laurent Tello avec Laurent Tello on
découvre que la nupes et donc née et
c'est vrai grâce à la brillance du lac
péruvien Titicaca distant de plus de
10000 km du siège de la France insoumise
il y a toujours un peu d'Amérique du Sud
quand Jean-Luc Mélenchon et dans les
parages
raconte aussi par le menu comment
François Hollande s'est préparé à
concourir la présidentielle en faisant
travailler deux équipes l'une conduite
par Julien Dray un sujet que Laurent
hello connaît bien je crois que le livre
précédent c'était il y a toujours c'est
toujours moi qui me charge du sale
boulot Baron Noir un jour Baron Noir
toujours alors il planche au domicile
dans son domicile du 14e l'autre équipe
elle turbine dans les locaux de l'ancien
président rue Rivoli et tout ça bien sûr
chacun
ignorant l'existence de l'autre ça n'a
pas marché pour 2022 on verra si ça
marche en 2027 il y aura bien une
troisième équipe et Laurent hello sera
derrière la porte
j'arrête là les anecdotes sont très sont
très nombreuses on se perd un peu dans
ce dédale d'une gauche dans le
brouillard condamné à s'accrocher à la
nupes étrange attelage électorale qui a
eu le mérite au moins de faire survivre
la gauche à quel prix jusqu'à quand
comment Sacher gère laurentello que on
est prêt au jury à relire la suite des
aventures de la nuit Pesse
[Applaudissements]
merci merci Bruno jeudi vous allez donc
pu découvrir les trois finalistes du
Prix du Livre politique 2023 le jury
s'est réuni ce matin et après
délibération à désigner donc un lauréat
on va très vite lever le suspense c'est
pour cela j'invite Roselyne Bachelot
ancienne ministre de la Culture
présidente du jury du Prix du Livre
politique à me rejoindre
[Applaudissements]
le suspense est encore insoutenable
et donc le prix du Livre politique et
remis à
Franz Olivier Gisbert pour histoire
intime de la Cinquième République c'est
le tome 2 et j'invite 30
[Applaudissements]
félicitations
voilà c'est bien
non je parle après tu parles après
[Musique]
toutes les personnes ici toutes les
personnes ici toi
Roselyne la présidente du jury Luce qui
nous traîne ici de temps en temps moi ça
fait des années l'organisatrice la
guerrière formidable je voudrais
applaudir à chaque fois tout le temps
[Applaudissements]
le Premier ministre madame Agacinski qui
a fait un très bon livre et puis mes
amis mimi et Loulou Michel cotta et
Louis Mermaz que je connais depuis 50
ans
je les salue ouais juste une belle fin
de vie enfin à la fin de vie je vais la
faire durer depuis longtemps possible
mais c'est vrai que ça fait du bien un
prix pour une raison très simple c'est
que ça aide le bouquin les bouquins il
faut les pousser pour qu'il marche tout
le monde sait ça et c'est toujours bon
pour les livres et
le grand merciment je vous remercier
évidemment le jury mais le grand
remerciement madame
la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
ma vieille copine Paulette de crème que
j'ai retrouvé mais depuis si longtemps
j'ai pas vraiment reconnu tout de suite
ça met du temps désolé mais le grand
remerciement je dois le faire pour
analyseur tu parlais de l'éditeur c'est
fondamental moi c'est vrai que j'écoute
assez peu les éditeurs en général bon il
y en a qui ont un peu une main sur moi
je pense évidemment à m'amuse Theresa
Cremisi ou bien il y a Muriel Bayer
enfin il y en a eu d'autres mais c'est
vrai que Ravel vie il m'a accouru après
pendant quelques semaines ou quelques
mois je suis difficilement trouvable
parce que j'habite Marseille je trouve
des tas de raisons pour pas monter à
Paris
finalement un jour je me retrouve devant
lui il me dit il faut que vous fassiez
ce livre il m'explique parce que vous
avez connu tous les présidents de la 5e
République
j'ai aperçu entre aperçu Pompidou et
Pompidou il me connaissait bien parce
que je racontais les conseils des
ministres tous les toutes les semaines
ça l'énervait beaucoup donc il
connaissait mon nom d'ailleurs on me la
présentait je ne sais pas Michel cotta
d'ailleurs on me l'a présenté il s'est
foutu de ma gueule il m'a dit tiens je
voyais pas comme ça puis après il est
parti parce qu'il était bon quand on
voyait les gens d'ailleurs c'est vrai je
sais pas mais il était moqueur toute
façon tu tu l'as connu c'était c'était
un moqueur avec un charisme fou c'est
pas on le voit comme un petit vieux et
quand on le voyait bon bah en vrai il
faisait 1 m 80 c'est pour ça c'est
l'avantage d'avoir connu les gens moi je
suis pas de l'école pledel je crois
qu'il faut voir les gens dont on parle
et c'est vrai que et c'est vrai que ben
quand on a vu Pompidou c'est autre chose
et puis
donc me dit c'est formidable parce que
comme vous avez tous connu c'est vrai
que j'ai pris des notes j'ai même tenu
mon journal j'en avais fait des pages et
des pages mais quand j'ai commencé à
lire mais qu'est-ce que c'est chiant
d'ailleurs enfin c'est vrai on a pas
envie de se remettre dedans et je dis je
me souviens très bien je lui ai dit oui
ça m'intéresse en fait c'était pas mais
mets-moi parce que c'est lui qui a
trouvé le système merci
Anna Cabana mais c'est pas moi qui ai eu
l'idée de faire ce mélange entre la vie
personnelle etc les amis en permanence
c'est ravalie il m'a fait le concept et
je l'ai fait comme ça comme comme il me
l'a indiqué
et à la fin de cette conversation je me
souviens je lui dis mais oui ce livre ce
sujet tout ça me passionne j'ai envie de
savoir comment on en est arrivé là parce
que c'est ça c'était la motivation c'est
à dire que elle a raison quand je
l'entendais mais c'était
je suis né avec un amour de la France
comme beaucoup d'immigrés souvent
d'ailleurs d'origine maghrébine j'en
connais plein qui sont venus avec un
amour de la France et ils arrivent dans
un pays où on est la France et un pays
qui dégringole avec comment dire les
rires sous les rires parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens inquiets malheureux et
puis il y a aussi beaucoup de gens qui
ricam ou qui brûle des poubelles parce
que c'est vrai que c'est marrant c'est
très drôle le mobilier urbain c'est bon
bref
et c'est le travail que j'ai essayé de
faire avec comment dire d'abord la
passion du journalisme parce que c'est
de l'histoire aussi c'est vrai mais
aussi le journaliste le journaliste
c'est magnifique c'est la meilleure
définition c'est peut-être celle de Lord
biverboch qui était un manga de la
presse britannique qui disait qui
mettait une pancarte partout dans ces
journaux où il y avait beaucoup de
journaux et c'était fait comme si le
monde avait été inventé ce matin et ça
j'aime ça dans ce métier c'est à dire
l'extraordinaire curiosité et puis aussi
la modestie qu'on doit avoir hélas
mais il devrait l'être parce que notre
métier au fond c'est quoi c'est souvent
expliqué des choses qu'on comprend pas
c'est ça aussi et puis c'est aussi comme
disait l'humoriste Georges Berlin show
c'est aussi confondre parfois une chute
de vélo et un effondrement de
civilisation parce qu'on en est là mais
c'est un beau métier parce que c'est un
métier qui doit vous apprendre tout le
temps à changer d'avis moi c'est ce que
je fais et c'est l'injonction que
m'avait donné Jean Daniel tu parlais de
mes maîtres à la Cabana c'est vrai
Jean-Daniel était un de mes premiers
maîtres avaient raison sur mes maîtres
François Furet l'historien qui était
d'ailleurs le maître de Rana Levy qui
est plus jeune que moi mais c'était
aussi les passer par par François Furet
grand historien de la de la Révolution
qu'il faut lire et puis et puis aussi
quand même Jacques Julia Jacques
Julliard c'est aussi je pense que c'est
au fond c'est peut-être l'homme qui mal
plus marqué parce que j'ai partout
l'impression que mon cerveau est le même
que celui déjà que je regarde le même
alors tu disais
tu disais bouddhiste spinosis tout ça
Anna Cabana c'est très juste je
rajouterais quand même la petite
dimension croyante chrétienne un peu
barrée qui est très importante et que je
partage avec mon ami Jacques juillet
alors j'ai juste terminé parce que bon
on vit tous on a le sentiment de vivre
avec classement ils sont dans les
chiffres des visites du commerce
extérieur les forums général de la par
exemple la richesse nationale par
habitant quand on compare on était dans
les cinq premiers dans les années 70 et
aujourd'hui nous sommes au 26e rang on
est peut-être à l'heure où on parle au
30e d'ailleurs parce que ça descend
toujours mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
foutu c'est pas foutu il y a toujours
moi j'ai l'amour de la politique
j'ai l'amour de la classe politique j'ai
eu la chance de rencontrer des
personnages absolument extraordinaires
dont je pends auquel je pense tous les
jours Pierre Messmer héros absolu et
héros de la guerre incroyable quand on
connaît sa vie d'ailleurs faut pas lire
ces mémoires pour connaître sa vie
puisque évidemment comme tous les héros
il raconte rien de ce qu'il a fait mais
ce type qui partait la nuit dans les
lignes ennemis pour amener avec quatre
copains un cadavre de pendant la
bataille de Bir-Hakeim c'est même pas
dans le cinéma il y a même pas une ligne
enfin tout le monde sait ça et ça c'est
des gens que j'ai fréquenté de près j'ai
eu la chance quand j'étais jeune j'avais
20 ans et il m'apprenait la vie parce
que parce qu'ils avaient vécu et puis je
peux parler aussi de Mitterrand il y a
pas une journée où je pense pas à lui
parce que il disait des trucs
incroyables dont on se rappelait tout le
temps parce que parce que c'est un
Pygmalion il aimait vous donner quoi et
puis je parle pas de Chirac aussi que
quelqu'un enfin je veux dire je peux pas
penser à lui n'est-ce pas
on rit tout de suite on rit parce que
c'était bon alors simplement évidemment
ils ont participé à la grande foirade
tous mais moi je fais pas leur procès
parce que je pense qu'il faut parler
aussi des Français non non je le fais un
peu pas trop pas trop parce que je les
aime et puis et puis il y a les Français
je suis là qu'on parle très bien les
Français après 1995 j'ai retrouvé ça des
notes c'est pour le troisième tome mais
c'est incroyable ce qui dit il en parle
il parle des Français comme De Gaulle
c'est-à-dire la machine enfin c'est
dingue tous ces gens qui font qui font
grève la France qui s'arrête parce
qu'ils veulent que les agents roulants
de la SNCF la RATP qui gagne plus de
façon qui partent plutôt à la retraite
qui partent à 50 ans avec plus de blé
mais ce pays est dingue voilà mais et ça
continue d'ailleurs et ça continue donc
moi ce que j'ai voulu faire à travers ça
c'est modestement parce que ce métier je
le répète est un métier de modestie
hélas qui n'est pas toujours exercé avec
modestie mais c'est d'essayer de
comprendre de faire parler avec
effectivement selon les règles que
m'avait donné
l'ami Rana Levy et ben de faire sans
arrêt d'éveil vient avec le passé
aujourd'hui hier etc et moi je vous dis
un truc je suis convaincu ça Anna Cabana
tout à fait raison moi je suis convaincu
au fond et c'est peut-être tu as raison
si je suis vache souvent c'est peut-être
aussi pour être écouté pour être entendu
en disant quand même les gars là vous
commencez à faire attention parce qu'on
est dans un déni total permanent et
absolue mais on secouant bien on va
peut-être arriver à réveiller les gens
mais je suis convaincu que la France
n'est pas finie enfin c'est grotesque ce
pays on a passé notre temps à leur faire
il retombe il ressuscite il meurt il
ressuscite et c'est pas la fin du monde
donc j'ai pas écrit un livre sur la
décadence française je pense que à un
moment donné il y aura
comme il y a eu en 1958 un sursaut le
livre il commence par le sursaut après
il y a la belle époque parce que c'était
la gestion des gaullistes parce qu'en
fait même Giscard utilisait les méthodes
gauliennes avec l'idée de bonne gestion
un puissant égale 2 pas de déficit pas
de trop de déséquilibre budgétaire en
fait etc pendantettement enfin c'était
il y a une espèce de logique après tout
ça c'est vrai mais vous allez voir un
moment donné ça reviendra donc ce sera
le quatrième tome peut-être mais je
serai pas là pour l'écrire le sursaut 2
merci
[Applaudissements]
mesdames Messieurs chers amis c'était
donc ce Prix du Livre politique
il y a certainement parmi vous celui ou
celle qui sera le président ou la
présidente du jury l'année prochaine
je voudrais donc vous emmener avec moi
quelques instants pour que vous soyez
parfaitement informés des pièges qui
vous seront tendus
vous allez donc recevoir un coup de
téléphone de l'espérance
d'être l'âme de ce prix
avec la secrétaire général Michel cotta
et là votre ego va fréquiller vous allez
vous dire je suis la présidente du jury
du Livre politique ça vraiment un rêve
de gosse enfin d'adolescentes
et puis un porteur va sonner à votre
porte
et vous allez voir arriver un paquet
contenant 28 livres à lire
et là vous vous allez vous dire dans
quelle piège est-ce que je me suis
fourré
et à ce moment où j'ai reçu les 28
livres et où je les ai posé dans ma
chambre bureau
j'ai pensé à Roger Frey
était un ami de mon père président du
Conseil constitutionnel ministre de
l'intérieur du général de Gaulle j'étais
toute jeune adolescente il m'avait dit
c'était incroyable toi tu seras ministre
rester quand même assez improbable il
m'avait donné un certain nombre de
conseils et dans les conseils qu'il
m'avait donné il m'avait dit on va
t'offrir des livres tu remercieras
immédiatement et surtout tu ne les liras
pas car les seuls livres intéressants
sont ceux qu'on achète soi-même
et en fait là ça n'a pas été vrai parce
que c'est 28 livres politiques que j'ai
tous lu comme l'ont fait tous les
membres du jury tous ces livres étaient
passionnants et tous ces livres dans ce
monde de bruit et de fureur que nous
vivons disaient tous ces livres disaient
quelque chose d'important et vous allez
maintenant les acheter et je vous invite
donc à les acheter
le deuxième élément c'est que ce jury
est composé des meilleurs plumes de la
presse française
tous des journalistes et je pensais que
par définition un journaliste c'était
une peau de vache
oui c'est vrai là j'ai entendu quelqu'un
dire c'est vrai
et je vous ai trouvé mesdames messieurs
finalement plein de bienveillance
peut-être vous êtes-vous dit je ferai
partie de la sélection de l'année
prochaine il faut mieux que j'assure mes
arrières enfin je ne sais pourquoi mais
vous avez été particulièrement attentif
et particulièrement bienveillant et nos
discussions ont été
oui vraiment très fructueuse très
amicale je voudrais que vous en soyez
remercier remercier de l'honneur que
vous m'avez fait dans cette année de
m'accueillir de m'accueillir parmi vous
alors on passe de cette succession de
coup de coeur un autre coup de coeur
bon bien sûr on a adoré leur entello je
dois dire que certainement
il m'étonnerait beaucoup qu'anidalgo
partent en vacances avec leur entée
l'eau je sais pas pourquoi mais paraîtra
assez difficile
Chloé Morin c'est un livre qu'il faut
que tous les politiques lisent parce que
véritablement c'est c'est un livre de
gouvernance extrêmement
utile et la lecture devrait en être
obligatoire pour les ministres et tous
les parlementaires et puis il y a le feu
d'artifice
c'est le livre de Franz Olivier Giesbert
moi j'ai un avantage sur toi France
c'est que j'avais neuf mois mon père m'a
emmené dans la réunion constitutive du
RPF et que le général de Gaulle mis à
embrassé sur la joue alors quand même je
voudrais pas jouer les Malines mais hein
oui ben je sais bien je sais bien les
liens qui unissent ça va à papa
reconstitution de ligne dissoute
association de malfaiteurs et tout
iguane mais en tout cas dans cette
histoire de la Cinquième République et
une chose que tu ne sais pas
c'est que au moment de la conférence de
presse la fameuse conférence de presse
du général de Gaulle en 1800 en 1958 en
ce qui était encore la gare d'Orsay
mon père était allé demander un
coupe-file à Olivier Guichard il avait
pas vu le général depuis 4 ou 5 ans
et papa on est partout
et donc nous étions tous les deux dans
cette gare d'Orsay
papa m'avait mis derrière un pilier
donc la phrase fameuse où je pense c'est
Pierre vient sans compter qui interpelle
le général de Gaulle en lui demandant
c'est Maurice diverger merci Jean-Louis
Maurice Duverger interpelle le général
de Gaulle en disant allez vous garantir
les libertés publiques et le général de
Gaulle lui répond il y a jamais à tenter
je n'ai fait que les défendre
pensez-vous qu'à 67 ans je vais
commencer une carrière de dictateur je
pense mais je demande des vérifications
que je suis la seule personne vivante à
avoir assisté à la conférence de presse
de 1958 c'est au moins le privilège de
l'âge donc l'histoire de la Cinquième
République que tu racontes
c'est mon histoire
et c'est notre histoire et je suis très
heureuse pour tout cela que tu aies
obtenu ce prix merci au jury merci à lui
merci à vous d'être là
[Applaudissements]
merci Roselyne Bachelot et encore
félicitations à vous Franz Olivier
Giesbert qui remporte donc le prix du
Livre politique pour histoire intime de
la Cinquième République aux éditions
Gallimard alors nous allons à présent
conclure cette matinée et je vais
laisser la parole à la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale il y a El brune
Pivet
je voudrais tout d'abord féliciter notre
heureux L'Oréal du livre du prix
politique donc je salue le travail je
voudrais remercier évidemment l'ensemble
des membres du jury tous les auteurs les
éditeurs qui se sont mobilisés si
nombreux pour cette 32e journée du Livre
politique merci à eux merci aussi
à l'espero pour ce rendez-vous réussi de
la culture et de la politique
pour moi pour nous l'une ne va pas sans
l'autre
je ne vais pas avoir une conclusion trop
longue mais je voudrais vous dire juste
quelques mots
l'humanisme n'est avec l'imprimerie
l'aspiration à la liberté fleurit avec
l'édition d'ouvrage critique et
philosophiques au temps des lumières et
les grandes figures de la Révolution
furent d'abord des auteurs avant de
devenir des députés
les pamphlets de CIS ou de Mirabeau les
oeuvres de Jean Sylvain Bailly ou de
Condorcet furent à la fois des livres et
des actes politiques qui en appelaient à
l'intelligence humaine à la raison pour
résoudre les grands problèmes politiques
et sociaux de leur temps
dans leur sillage combien de députés
sont devenus écrivains
et aussi de la martine a aimé Césaire et
d'Eugène Sue à Léopold Sédar Senghor
combien de grands écrivains ont
absolument tenu à devenir député le plus
célèbre Victor Hugo avait conscience de
cette parenté entre livre et libre il
disait
la pensée est plus qu'un droit c'est le
souffle même de l'homme
qui entrave la pensée attente à l'homme
même
parler écrire imprimer publier ce sont
là les ondes sonores de la pensée
et en 1878 devant conclure conclure un
congrès littéraire il fit lui aussi le
choix de la concision en déclarant
la lumière est dans le livre
ouvrez le livre tout grand
laissez le rayonner laissez le faire
je ne dirai pas mieux que lui merci à
vous tous qui avez fait rayonner les
livres et la culture aujourd'hui à
l'Assemblée nationale où les écrivains
et les penseurs seront toujours les
bienvenus pour nous aider à préparer
l'avenir je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente merci à vous
tous de nous avoir suivis sur LCP je
vous donne rendez-vous à 16h30 sur la
chaîne parlementaire pour la remise du
Prix étudiant du Livre politique LCP et
du prix de la BD politique LCP à tout à
l'heure
[Musique]